i think he's going i
catch it here oh see so when he's
falling i have that break right there
do you yield
is not necessarily external
do it internally
don't pull the knife away don't keep it
the throat takes him off of you the
throat takes his grip
off
okay we'll stop there okay
so he goes
i'm not trying to do that
i'm not hitting him so hard that he
falls down and his feet come
forward that's not what i'm doing
i have to tilt him i have to tilt him
and then i have to rotate
it takes more energy to create a toffee
turkey effect
on the 12 6 line that means you have to
be capable of generating that energy
that means
if whatever energy he generated i have
to overcome that energy
that's not what we're doing let's look
at the arm
of the inward spiral
yeah the heaven hat okay
right now as you use it you're seeing
kind of
arm bar stuff okay
so you go like this and then you go
move but if you look at the spiral
let's let me have him this is just a
vector
force vector so at this point
he feels the spiral he feels the
resistance
okay and my job is to get rid of that
so if that's his mass coming in
i'm gonna go around it which you guys
are all doing
but all you're doing now is putting it
right there
now you push on that but now and if you
pay attention
you stop the spiral or you shrunk it so
small
that it's not obeying the yin yang grid
on on your
within your four corners so it's staying
for example
my yang line is staying on my yarn line
which is why it projects like young okay
the hand is supposed to go around
it goes from the middle around
back to the other side and what you're
going to find is that
the elbow is actually going around his
energy
it's not going this way
as he pushes its yielding
around so that's going to be our drill
we'll be here i'll feel him on the elbow
and i'm going to continue the spiral to
let him walk it
those little extra one to two inches is
all you want
okay what you're doing now is you don't
have it
so we'll go slow and he goes
and here's where you get caught
keep the spiral going and you take one
to two more inches in
obviously here no he's coming in
and he's stuck you see that's where you
hit him
keep the spiral going and he comes in
that is not the same as we go here stuck
and he and i go like this you see
that's not the spot i'm keeping the
spiral
boom stop
my hand is still going forward is how
you'll know the difference
i go around boom stock here's where you
usually hit the guy
once my hat is going to go backwards
that's not it
my hand will go forward
you got it
stop that's where you hit him keep this
bottle going
allow
when he comes in and you feel that he's
pushing on you you see
it triggers you well the power goes
and you try to shove it back and your
technique goes like this
he never comes up he never comes forward
i don't really have control of his body
he's let me throw him backwards
okay so we're just taking all this out
and just dealing with he's coming oh
there it is right there
that's what you guys feel you feel
everyone's gonna feel that part
it's now what do you do after that okay
what you're supposed to do is free it
so your tactic should be consciously
chosen right now
it is not consciously chosen so if he's
coming in
you can you can do that you see i
consciously chose to do it right now i'm
going to consciously choose
i can stick him okay and now
i'm going to let him free
i'm going to deconstruct the contention
point
so i'm conscious consciously stuck
that's where you guys push you're going
to feel that in the technique
but let it go
won't
let it go
don't let it go don't let it go with
movement
it's in the spiral itself is the point
of making
it's in the spiral itself
[Music]
okay let's go okay if he's grabbing me
i'm not supposed to just be moving his
arm
where where he's touching me i move his
body
so the same thing goes if i'm if i'm
working here
i'm moving his butt
it doesn't change here like even though
i'm here
i'm going to
at what rate when he heals so he's
pushing
and he's not not gonna come forward i'm
not blocking him
i'm stuck right here and trying to come
forward because i'm
i'm down in his feet he tries to walk
you can see his balance is going to be
taken
you see that but you can't have it dead
you're in his body you're controlling
him
and that's what starts to turn him that
when i
because i need to be in his body to
start doing the movement part
okay so i'm in his body and i'm not
working with his
neck and working
with his forward energy to get in his
body okay
so he's pushing
push really hard okay he's really hot
that's what he's doing he's pushing
really hard and round vectoring
and i'm going to do this spiral with my
body to turn him
you're going to have to do something
else okay so we're stuck here
and i'm controlling him and i'm gonna
turn
his energy that forward energy into the
tilt
oh
and that same contention point
i have to release it like bring him into
the vortex
so it's not one push like this i'm
holding him and i go like this
you're just gonna send him back now
which is what you guys are doing
you need his energy to rotate and go
topsy turn
he's pushing
oh he's driving right driving
remember i need to tilt him and then
i'll turn him
right now i need to get the tilt and the
beginning of the turn
what is how far he comes forward
when you go like this he's not coming
forward i want him to come
forward so my
okay let's try it okay uh this is not a
technique
for somebody that bends backwards on you
i don't really think you need a
technique for that person
you know what i mean he bends i feel
like he bends backwards
you could even go like i said but if
you're
tactically you're fine this is a
technique for somebody whose
aggression has solidified their center
how do i turn
that person okay
so the next little micro drill
is i'm bringing him to my hip
i'm freeing him he's here and i go
stuck
remember working with his energy
my father may not it doesn't matter um
[Music]
okay i didn't enter yet try it so
you should be drilled
[Music]
home
nobody
try to relax don't worry you're gonna go
you don't have to do anything okay just
relax
go up
better all right
[Music]
okay so remember to do idi miyashi
which way they're supposed to be going
that way
i don't use me i'm not using this to do
the throw
they were already going that way okay
and this is how you get them going that
way
so that's the move
[Music]
absorb
so
okay
contestant
too weak it's too weak do it again
get your mid-foot weight you'll fall
over
you're not letting them in enough you're
feeling threatened let them in
all the way let them in okay that's an
external yield though
cycle through oh what a glass you're
just so strong
it's external try to get it more
internal
don't let the bigger guy trigger you
you're already contesting right when you
switch you're like oh i can do this size
we don't get to pick our size
yeah get your hip in there get the
ground vector on the left foot do it
again on the larger
you got to get the left foot ground
vector now
try it again don't hope for it do it
better cycle through
good shorter movements right tighten it
up
try it again get your left arm more
engaged or your right arm
right on more engaged
oh try it again ground vector left foot
there you go
[Music]
so
[Applause]
oh i always want to push on people
get that ground vector
yield internally don't let the elbow
back
better
you let that elbow back that's where you
spiral you're getting stuck
on him because you feel this pressure
you push on it
step with that though
cycle through
ground vacuum
that's it
you're keeping them out do it again same
side
in release there it is same thing here
in release